This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanthan. In the hit television show Ozark, a bright financial advisor finds himself suddenly working on the wrong side of the law. What's our story for the kids? Well, we could tell them the truth, Wendy. How would that be? Following a series of bad decisions by his business partner, Marty Bird, played by Jason Bateman, begins working for a drug cartel. I want you to be ready to set up shop within a week. Yeah, the Marty.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。在热播电视剧《黑钱胜地》中，一位精明的理财顾问发现自己突然开始为违法分子工作。我们给孩子们编个什么故事呢？嗯，我们可以告诉他们真相，温迪。那样怎么样？在合伙人马蒂·伯德——由杰森·贝特曼饰演——做出一系列糟糕的决定后，他开始为一个贩毒集团工作。我要你在一个星期内准备好开张。没错，马蒂。
When I drive by you house, there better be a foreshale sign on the wrong. Almost from the start, the body start to fall. People get thrown off balconies, people get shot, people are electrocuted. When government officials get involved, more violence unfolds. People betray one another. They cheat each other. They act in selfish and short-sighted ways. Let me just jog your memory for a minute. There was an innocent man who was murdered. Gary, he was a good man.
当我开车经过你家时，最好能看到一块待售的标志。几乎从一开始，尸体就开始不断出现。有人被从阳台上扔下去，有人被枪杀，有人触电身亡。当政府官员卷入其中时，更多的暴力随之爆发。人们互相背叛。他们互相欺骗。他们的行为自私且目光短浅。让我为你提个醒。曾有一个无辜的人被谋杀。加里，他是个好人。
You might say this is the genre of the drug movie or television show. You see it in critically acclaimed TV shows like The Wire and Breaking Bad, and in movies such as Traffic and Scarface. Shell off to my live friend! and in movies such as traffic and Scarface. Running through these dramas, we sense the irresistible power of drug addiction, the implacable draw of heroin or cocaine or methamphetamine, the chaos and crime that follow everywhere the drug trade is blight. I've watched many of these TV shows in movies as entertainment. For many years,
你可能会说，这是毒品电影或电视剧的固有题材。你在广受好评的电视剧《火线》和《绝命毒师》中都能看到，还有电影《毒品网络》和《疤面煞星》。“滚开，我的活宝贝！”在这些戏剧中，我们能感受到毒品成瘾无法抗拒的力量，海洛因、可卡因或甲基苯丙胺那不可动摇的吸引力，以及毒品交易作为一场灾难所到之处带来的混乱和犯罪。多年来，我作为娱乐看过许多这样的电视剧和电影。
I also reported on the work of researchers who studied the science of drug addiction. But some time ago I came by a mind-bending idea that transformed my understanding of addiction. It challenged how I think about drugs and what it means to be addicted. And it told me that as gripping as TV shows in movies about the drug trade might be, they don't begin to capture the profound story of addiction in all of our lives. of addiction in all of our lives. Today we begin with a story we are telling across two episodes. It will change the way you think about your brain and offer some profound insights into what it means to live a life of happiness and contentment. Pleasure, pain and balance this week on Hidden Brain.
我也报道过研究毒品成瘾科学的科学家的工作。但不久前，我偶然听到一个颠覆性的观点，它改变了我对成瘾的理解。它挑战了我对毒品以及成瘾意味着什么的看法。它告诉我，尽管关于毒品交易的电视剧和电影引人入胜，但它们根本无法捕捉到我们所有人生活中关于成瘾的深刻故事。我们所有人生活中关于成瘾的深刻故事。今天，我们从一个分为两集讲述的故事开始。它将改变你对大脑的看法，并就过上幸福满足的生活意味着什么提供一些深刻的见解。本周的《隐藏的大脑》将探讨：快乐、痛苦与平衡。
All of us think we know what addictions look like. We've seen the movies and TV shows about gang violence and drug dens. At Stanford University Anna Lemke studies the science of addiction. She argues our conception of addiction is far too narrow. Anna Lemke, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you for having me. I'm excited to be here. Anna, you're a practicing psychiatrist in the heart of Silicon Valley, and I think of California's Bay Area as perhaps the, you know, the richest part of the richest country in the history of humankind. So a time traveler from the 17th century might assume that, you know, even if the streets were not paved with gold, at a minimum, people would be very happy with so much material success. Is your psychiatric practice empty? Ha, I still marvel at the gap between how people present outwardly and the truth of their inner experience. We see people every day who seem to have everything
我们所有人都认为自己知道成瘾是什么样子的。我们看过关于帮派暴力和瘾君子聚集地的电影和电视剧。在斯坦福大学，安娜·兰姆克研究的是成瘾科学。她认为我们对成瘾的理解过于狭隘了。安娜·兰姆克，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢邀请我来。我很兴奋能来到这里。安娜，你是一位在硅谷腹地执业的精神病学家，我认为加州的湾区可以说是人类历史上最富裕的国家中最富裕的地区。因此，一个来自17世纪的时光旅行者可能会认为，哪怕街道不是用黄金铺成的，至少面对如此巨大的物质成功，人们也会非常快乐。你的精神科诊所门可罗雀吗？哈哈，我至今仍然对人们外表的表现与他们内心体验的真实情况之间的鸿沟感到惊叹。我们每天都会看到这样的人，他们似乎拥有一切
you could ever want, wealth, beauty, meaningful work, and yet when you look under the hood, they're miserably unhappy. So over time, on a you've seen more and more patients suffering from depression, anxiety, and chronic pain, ailments for which they are hard-pressed sometimes to find a source or a cause. And as you say, often these are healthy, affluent, educated people with seemingly everything they could want in life. One patient of yours was a young physician with a very promising career. Can you describe what he was like when you first met him?
你可能想要的东西：财富、美貌、有意义的工作，然而当你深入了解时，他们却痛苦不堪。所以随着时间的推移，安娜，你看到越来越多的患者饱受抑郁、焦虑和慢性疼痛的折磨，对于这些病症，他们有时很难找到病源或病因。正如你所说，通常这些人都是健康、富裕、受过良好教育的人，在生活中似乎拥有一切想要的东西。你的其中一位患者是一位年轻的医生，有着非常前途无量的职业生涯。你能描述一下你刚认识他时的样子吗？
Delightful young man, handsome, kind, thoughtful, considerate. He came to me in fact because he got considerable considerable considerable considerable considerable considerable considerable considerable considerable considerable considerable considerable considerable considerable considerable considerable considerable considerable considerable considerable considerable considerable considerable considerable considerable considerable considerable considerable considerable considerable considerable considerable considerable considerable considerable considerable considerable considerable considerable considerable online gambling sports betting. And his story went like this. He was a very successful high school and collegiate athlete on Division 1, all kinds of accolades, really a remarkable athlete. And that cycle of engagement in high level athletics, the adrenaline that goes along with high-level competition,
一个讨人喜欢的年轻人，英俊、善良、体贴、周到。他来找我其实是因为他获得了相当多的、相当多的、相当多的……在线赌博、体育博彩。他的故事是这样的：他曾是一名非常成功的高中和大学一级联赛运动员，获得过各种荣誉，确实是一位非常出色的运动员。而这种参与高水平竞技的循环，伴随着高水平竞技的肾上腺素，
the wins, the losses that absolutely was his jam, right? It kept him busy and engaged and really, really happy. But when that career came to its natural end, like so many high-level athletes, there was sort of a free-falling disappointment to kind of an existential, profound disappointment, a bit of an identity crisis. And although he was headed to medical school, which you know, gave him kind of a new identity to latch onto, he really missed that cycle of intensity that he got through participation in sports. And then he was invited by his collegiate buddies to participate in Fantasy Football in a Fantasy Football League. And you know they all get together and they
赢球和输球，绝对是他的最爱，对吧？这让他忙碌、投入，并且真的、真的很开心。但当那种职业生涯自然走到尽头时，就像许多高水平运动员一样，随之而来的是一种自由落体般的失望，一种存在主义的、深刻的失望，甚至有点身份危机。尽管他正要进入医学院学习，你知道，这给了他一个新的身份去依附，但他真的很怀念通过参加体育运动获得的这种高强度循环。后来，他应大学死党的邀请参加了梦幻足球（美职足幻想联赛）。你知道，他们聚在一起，
choose their teams and then there was, you know, minor money involved in that. But he got really, really into it. More so than his buddies from college. And that was really almost the spark for him then to begin to want to engage athletically through sports betting and sports gambling. And you know it started with 50 bucks, 100 bucks. And at this time he's now started medical school, he's doing his pre-med courses, you know he's getting ready for his clinical years.
挑选他们的球队，其中涉及少量的金钱。但他真的、真的很投入。甚至比他大学死党还要投入。这几乎成了他的导火索，让他随后开始通过体育博彩和体育赌博来寻找竞技的参与感。你知道，最初是50美元、100美元。而此时他已经开始读医学院了，在上医学预科课程，你知道的，正在为临床实习年做准备。
He had this phone, he could pull it out. During grand rounds you know when he was supposed to be listening to the speaker and scroll through, you know, results of all the different sports, and then he could place a bet. And that accessibility just absolutely ensnared him. And he found himself completely caught up in it to the point where he was now spending not hundreds of dollars, but thousands of dollars, not monthly but weekly and eventually daily. And in about six months he completely spent the trust fund that he had inherited from his parents in order to pay for medical school. He was so ashamed that he didn't tell anybody and he thought to himself, well, if I can just win, then I can get all the money back and then I'll be fine. So he took out an
他手里拿着手机，随时可以拿出来。在教学查房时，你知道的，当他本该听主讲人发言的时候，他却在浏览各种体育比赛的结果，然后他就可以下注了。这种触手可得的便利彻底迷住了他。他发现自己完全深陷其中，以至于他花的不再是几百美元，而是几千美元，不是按月计算，而是按周，最后甚至是按天。在大约六个月的时间里，他完全花光了从父母那里继承来用于支付医学院学费的信托基金。他羞愧难当，不敢告诉任何人，他心里想：嗯，只要我能赢回来，那我就可以把所有的钱都赢回来，然后我就没事了。于是他在没有告诉任何人的情况下贷款了
enormous loan without telling anybody to pay for medical school and he thought, okay, I'm gonna put it in the bank, you know, I'm gonna pay it back and instead he gambled that away too. that away too. Anna had another patient who started doing something that might seem even more harmless than sports betting. So this was somebody who just found himself really getting intense pleasure out of the cycle of shopping online. He would spend quite a bit of time searching for different items that he was interested in buying
巨额资金来支付医学院的学费，他心想，好吧，我要把它存进银行，你知道的，我会把它还上的，结果他又把那些钱赌光了。把那些钱赌光了。安娜还有另一个患者，他开始做一件看起来甚至比体育博彩还要无害的事情。这个人发现自己在网上购物的循环中获得了极大的快乐。他会花相当多的时间搜索他想买的不同商品，
and the process of kind of like the treasure hunting was very, I'm entrancing and rewarding for him. All kind of building up slowly to the point where he would choose the items that he would buy, and then buy it. And then he would be waiting in anticipation for it to be delivered to his home, and all of that was very pleasurable. And then it would be delivered, and he would open it and take it out, and it was the thing
而这种类似寻宝的过程对他来说非常迷人且具有回报感。这一切都在慢慢积累，直到他选定要买的商品，然后买下它。接着，他会满怀期待地等待快递送到家里，所有这一切都给他带来了极大的快乐。然后快递送到了，他打开包装把它拿出来，这就是他想要的东西，感觉太棒了，对他来说简直就是美妙绝伦。因此，由于这个循环对他的吸引力太大了，他开始越来越多地这样做。他开始依赖这种循环作为调节情绪的生理拐杖。但随着时间的推移，他发现这个循环变得越来越短，从中获得的期待和快乐也越来越少，以至于他一打开盒子拿到订购的东西，
that he wanted, and it felt so good, and it was just, you know, wonderfulness for him. So because that cycle was so entrancing for him, he started to do it more and more. And he kind of came to rely on it as a physiologic crutch for managing his mood. But over time, what he found was that the cycle got shorter and shorter and the anticipation and pleasure that he got from it got less and less to the point where as soon as he opened the box and got what he had ordered,
这一切就结束了，然后他又会泡在网上试图购买下一件东西。最后，他的屋子里堆满了不需要也不想要的杂货，身上背着数万美元的信用卡债务。然而即便如此，他还是停不下来。所以他开始做的最后一招，就是买一些便宜的商品，比如钥匙扣、马克杯、帽子、便宜的太阳镜，这些都是他不需要也不想要的。然后他一拿到货就把它们退掉。哇。因为他不需要也不想要，然后一拿到手，他就把它们退掉。哇。因为他没有钱，但他打破不了购物的循环。我想谈谈最后一位患者，一个你称之为雅各布的男士，同时给听众提个醒：
it was over and then he'd be online again trying to buy the next thing. And eventually he ended up with rooms in his house full of stuff that he didn't need or want and tens of thousands of dollars of credit card debt. And yet even then he couldn't stop. So what he started to do is kind of a last resort is he bought like these cheap items, key chains, mugs, caps, cheap sunglasses, things he didn't need or want. And then as soon as he got them he would return them. Wow. Because he didn't need or want, and then as soon as he got them, he would return them. Wow. Because he didn't have any money, but he couldn't break the shopping cycle. I want to talk about one last patient, a man you call Jacob, and a note for listeners
接下来的这个故事涉及性和自杀。当你第一次见到雅各布时，他已经中年，甚至可能还要大一点。他的故事是怎样的，安娜？雅各布是一位斯坦福大学的科学家。顺便说一下，我要强调的是，我获得了患者的许可来讲述他们的故事。我使用了化名并隐藏了其他身份特征。所以雅各布是一位斯坦福大学的科学家，他来找我寻求帮助，具体是因为严重的性瘾、性爱、色情作品以及强迫性手淫。
that this next story includes references to both sex and suicide. Jacob was middle-aged or maybe even a little older when you first met him. What was a story, Anna? Jacob was a Stanford scientist. And by the way, let me just emphasize that I got permission from my patients to relay their stories. And I used pseudonyms and hide other identifying features. So Jacob was a Stanford scientist who came to me seeking help specifically for a severe sex addiction, a sex pornography compulsive masturbation.
他所描述的是，在90年代他使用色情制品并手淫，你知道的，频率甚至达到每天一次，但这从来没有到失控的地步。他依然能够作为一名父亲、一名丈夫正常生活。他在自己的职业生涯中很成功。但随着互联网的出现，特别是在2000年代初智能手机的出现，他发现自己对这种追求变得无法控制了，也就是说，他每天花更多的小时观看越来越多的色情制品，一直持续到深夜，甚至因为在前一晚整晚都在看色情制品、反复手淫，导致他没有出席他本应发表讲话并准备好发表演讲的会议，
And what he described was in the 90s he used pornography and he masturbated, you know, as much as daily, but it was never unmanageable. He was still able to function as a father, as a husband. He was successful in his profession. But with the advent of the internats and especially in the early 2000s in the smartphone, he found that this pursuit of his became unmanageable, which is to say that he was using more and more pornography for more hours every day, lead into the night, not showing up at a conference that he was supposed to speak at, prepared to give that speech because he had been up the entire night before of watching pornography, repeatedly masturbating,
随着时间的推移，他需要更强烈的形式才能达到同样的效果。于是他从那种平淡无奇的色情制品升级到更偏门、更变态的色情制品，后来色情制品本身也不够满足了，于是他开始去现场表演并与妓女见面，最终，你知道的，他的瘾发展到他开始进入聊天室，在聊天室里和其他人做一些危险的事情，把他所有能用的时间都用来从事这项活动，以至于他的生活基本上彻底崩溃了，他的妻子离开了他，他甚至萌生了结束自己生命的念头，甚至在办公室附近找了一个地方，考虑在那里上吊自杀。当然，这些案例各不相同。网上购物和赌博不一样，赌博和色情制品也不一样。但渐渐地，安娜开始看到它们之间的联系，不仅在这些患者之间，而且延伸到了许多没有向精神科医生寻求帮助的人身上。比如她自己。
and over time he needed more and more potent forms to get the same effect. So he escalated from sort of vanilla toast pornography to more deviant forms of pornography and then pornography itself, was an adequate, so then he was going to live shows and meeting up with prostitutes and eventually you know his addiction progressed to the point where he was going into chat rooms, doing dangerous things with other people in chat
你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。在斯坦福大学多年的执业过程中，精神科医生安娜·兰姆克发现，许多住在湾区的人——美国最富裕的地区之一——正饱受一种奇怪的怪病的折磨。尽管在教育和物质财富方面取得了巨大成功，但她的许多患者却并不快乐。有一次，安娜在自己身上看到了某种东西，这让她想到了她正在治疗的患者。安娜，我想把镜头聚焦到你40岁左右的那段生活。那时你的生活正发生着什么？那时我的生活很好。你知道，我的婚姻很美满。我的孩子们很健康。我的工作
rooms, spending all of his available time engaged in this activity to the point that essentially his life completely fell apart, his wife left him, and he was thinking about ending his life and even found a spot near his office where he thought about hanging himself. Each of these cases, of course, is different. Online shopping is not the same as gambling, and gambling is not the same thing as pornography. But in time, Ana came to see connections, not just between these patients, but to many people who are not seeking help from a psychiatrist. People like herself.
很有回报且有意义。对于一个40岁左右的女性来说，我的健康状况相对较好，所以一切都很好。那么，你一直都很喜欢阅读，大约在这个时候，你爱上了一套非常受欢迎的书籍系列。是什么？是《暮光之城》系列。你能跟我讲讲《暮光之城》系列大概讲的是什么吗？我承认我没有读过这些书。它们的大致情节是什么？大体情节是什么？嗯，你知道的，我接触到《暮光之城》是因为我把孩子送到小学，当时有一群妈妈聚在一起。
You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. Over many years of practice at Stanford University, psychiatrist Anna Lemke has found that lots of people living in the Bay Area, one of the wealthiest parts of the United States, was suffering from a strange malady. Despite being blessed with great success in terms of education and material wealth, many of her patients were unhappy. At one point Anna saw something in herself that reminded her of the patients she was treating. Anna, I want to zoom into your life around the time you turned 40. What was going on in your life at this time? My life was good then. You know, my marriage was fine. My kids were healthy. My work was
梅根是其中一位妈妈，也是我的朋友，她们当时都在歇斯底里地大笑，我走过去说：“嘿，有什么好笑的？”梅根说：“哦，我一直在读一本爱情小说，我简直太喜欢了，我走进书店想买续集，却找不到。于是我走到书店老板面前说，‘嘿，你知道续集在哪里吗？’他说，‘在青少年区。’”没错。于是所有的妈妈都笑翻了。
rewarding and meaningful. I was in relatively good health for a 40-ish year-old woman, so things were good. Now, you've always loved reading and around this time you fell in love with a very popular book series. What was it? It was the Twilight Saga. And can you tell me a little bit about what the Twilight Saga is? I confess I have not read the books. What is their broad plot and what is the good plot? What is that broad plot and what is it? Well, you know, I was turned on to the Twilight Saga when I dropped my kids off to elementary school and there was a group of moms clustered around.
她们觉得这是最好笑的事情。但她说：“不过你们一定要读读。太棒了。”于是我说：“好吧，梅根，它叫什么名字？因为我一直在寻找一本好书，对吧？”她说：“哦，它叫《暮光之城》。”我想，好吧，我来试试。结果它对我产生了绝对的魔力。就好像我这辈子从来没读过小说一样，突然之间，这本关于一群十几岁的吸鬼四处乱跑、互相咬脖子的小说，彻底把我迷住了。这真的很诡异。
Megan was one of the moms, my friend, and they were all laughing hysterically and I went over and I said, hey, what's so funny. And Megan said, oh, I've been reading this romance novel that I absolutely love and I went into the bookstore to try to get the sequel and I couldn't find it. So I went up to the bookstore owner and I said, hey, you know, where's the the sequel? And he said, it's in the teenager section. Right. So all the moms started cracking up.
所以《暮光之城》这些书最终衍生出了一系列非常受欢迎的电影。我想播放一段其中一部电影的片段。一个名叫贝拉的十几岁女孩正在质问她认识的一个男孩爱德华，关于他真实的本性。我知道你是什么。看到了。离开。看到了。吸血鬼。
They thought that was the funniest thing. But she said, but you guys have to read it. It's so good. So I said, okay, Megan, what is it called? Because I'm always looking for a good read, right? She said, oh, it's called the Twilight Saga. So I thought, okay, I'll give it a try. And it was absolutely mesmerizing for me. It was as if I had never read a novel in my life, and all of a sudden, this novel about a bunch of teenage vampires running around biting each other on the neck, it just absolutely transported me. It was really weird.
你害怕吗？不。好吧，这里有很多，你知道的，屏息凝神的停顿，但我听到的是，你知道的，奇幻、超自然的东西，但听起来像是一个足够无辜的消遣，安娜。哦，一个足够无辜的消遣？当然。一切总是从无辜开始的。当然，你知道，确实如此，但发生的事情是，它改变了我当时的感受，
So the Twilight books eventually spawned a very popular series of films. I want to play your clip from one of those movies. A teenage girl named Bella is confronting a boy she knows, Edward, about his true nature. I know what you are. See it. Outbound. See it. Vampire.
这种感觉引起了如此深刻的共鸣，以至于我想要不断重现那种感觉。那是一种什么感觉？那基本上是一种“非我”的感觉。当我阅读《暮光之城》系列时，它只是把我带到了另一个时间和地点，以至于我完全忘记了自我。而这种遗忘自我显然是我需要也想要的。你知道，我读完整套书，我想大概有四本书，然后我想再次重现那种感觉，所以我又把整套书读了一遍。哇。很愉快，但没有第一次那么愉快。但到那时，我已经完全沉迷于吸血鬼爱情小说这一整个类型了。于是我开始投入越来越多的大量时间、精力和创造力去获取和阅读吸血鬼爱情小说。你知道的，开始时似乎很无辜，但它变成了一种
Are you afraid? No. Okay, so there are a lot of, you know, breathless pauses here, but I'm hearing, you know, fantasy, paranormal stuff, but it sounds like an innocent enough pastime, Ana. Oh, an innocent enough pastime? Sure. It always starts out, innocence. And of course, you know, it was, but what happened was it changed the way I felt in the moment,
执念。当吸血鬼爱情小说被我读完后，我又转向了狼人爱情小说，接着是死灵法师、预言家，以及各种各样的超自然爱情小说。你在哪里获取这些书的？我住在一个小图书馆旁边，那里的藏书很有限。所以当我读完了当地图书馆有限的藏书后，要么骑自行车去总图书馆，要么通过馆际互借订购。而且你知道，其中一些爱情小说有非常暴露的封面。比如有些封面是一个穿着暴露的猛男，封面上有个健硕的家伙，站在船头什么的。
in a way that resonated so deeply that I wanted to keep recreating that feeling. And what was that feeling? It was essentially a feeling of non-being. While I was reading the Twilight saga, it just transported me to another time and place such that I completely forgot myself. And that self-forgetting was clearly something that I needed and wanted. You know, I read the whole saga, I think it's like four books, and then I wanted to recreate that feeling again, so I read the whole saga again. Wow. Pleasurable, but not as pleasurable as the first time around. But by then I was completely tapped into this whole genre of vampire romance novels. And so I started to invest larger and larger amounts of time, energy, and creativity into obtaining and reading vampire romance novels. You know, seemingly innocent to start with, but it became a bit of an
比如，我可不想在任何地方被别人看到我在读这种书。于是安娜想出了一个方法，把她正在读的书对家人和朋友隐瞒起来。我没有向任何人透露过这一点。这太糟糕了。但我实际上会把这本书夹在另一本书里，这样如果我的某个孩子路过或者我丈夫路过，我看起来就像是在读另一本别的书。哇。比如医学杂志什么的。除了那可能并不能真正骗过他们，因为，你知道的，他们知道我不会花那么多时间去读医学杂志。
obsession and when I ran out of vampire romance novels, I moved on to Werewolf romance novels and then there was necromancers and sous-sayers and all kinds of paranormal romance novels. Where were you procuring these books? So I live right next to a little library, which has a limited collection. So when I went through the limited collection at my local library, I either biked over to the main library or you can order through the interlibrary loan. And you know, some of these romance novels have very revealing covers. Like it was some modest ripper with some hunk on the cover, you know, at the prow of a ship or something.
我以前在八年级时也这么干过，安娜。我觉得，你知道的，书里夹书的把戏是我在八年级时就掌握得炉火纯青的技能。我知道，我知道，我是四十多岁才发现这招的，但我能告诉你吗，我是个大器晚成的人。所以安娜，有一次，你对这种文学的热爱在从纸质书转向电子领域时得到了强力加持。
Like, I wouldn't want to be seen reading that anywhere. So Anna came up with a way to hide what she was reading from her family and friends. I haven't revealed this to anybody. This is terrible. But I would actually put the book inside another book so that if one of my kids came by or my husband came by, I could look like I was reading the other book. Wow. Like a medical journal or something. Except that might not really trick them because like, you know, they would know that I wouldn't spend that much time reading a medical journal.
告诉我那是怎么发生的。嗯，我的朋友苏珊说：“你应该买个Kindle，这样你就不用随身带着这些厚重的书了。”Kindle当时刚出来。当然我很喜欢这个想法，因为这样获取很方便。但很快我也开始经常上Amazon查找，你知道的，类似于《暮光之城》的书。你猜怎么着？正如我们现在都知道的那样，Amazon会向你推荐这些书。所以Amazon替我完成了这项工作。我所要做的就是看一眼我的信息流，然后说：“哦，他们在告诉我应该读这本。他们在告诉我应该读那本。”在后来的过程中，
I mean, I used to do this in eighth grade, Anna. I felt like, you know, the trick of the book inside the book was something I had perfected in eighth grade. I know, I know, and I discovered it in my 40s, but can I tell you, I was a late bloomer. So at one point, Anna, your love of this literature received a turbocharge when you moved from the printed page to the electronic domain.
我还发现你可以在Amazon上获取免费书籍。所以只要是免费的、属于言情类别的书，我都会下载并阅读。这对我来说真的是末日的开始，因为一旦我有了那个电子阅读器，我基本上就成了一个连环阅读者。就像我一读完一本书，要么从当地图书馆借一本，要么在Amazon上买另一本。这些全都是言情小说。我甚至到了这种地步：每当我不用做那些我绝对必须做的事情——比如为了工作或为了家庭——我都在读言情小说。
Tell me how that happened. Well my friend Susan said, you should get a Kindle because then you don't have to be carrying these books around. Kindles had just come out then. And of course that was very, I liked that idea because it would be easy access. But pretty soon I also started regularly going on Amazon and looking for, you know, things that were similar to the Twilight saga. And guess what? Amazon will suggest those to you as we all know now. And so the Amazon did the work for me. All I had to do was look in my feed and say, oh, they're telling me I should read this one. They're telling me I should read that one. And like later on in the process,
后来发展到，这就是我唯一想做的事。我不再享受任何其他事情。我甚至不想和我的孩子们或丈夫在一起，对吧？我只想快点把这些时间打发过去，好让我能回去读言情小说。另一件我只有在事后才意识到的是，
I also discovered that you can get free books on Amazon. So anything that was free, that was in the romance category, I would download and read. And that was really the beginning of the end for me, because once I had that electronic reader, I essentially became a chain reader. Like as soon as I finished one book, I would either borrow from the local library or buy on Amazon another book. These were all romance novels. And I got to a point where whenever I wasn't doing something that I absolutely had to do like for my work or my family, I was reading romance novels.
这些尺度较小的言情小说——其中的性爱场景并不是超级大尺度——虽然它对我渐渐失去了吸引力。现在我需要尺度更大的言情小说才能获得我一直在寻找的那种刺激。为了获得我一直在寻找的那种刺激。所以此时这已经不再是关于阅读的快乐或你对语言的热爱了，它变成了别的东西。哦，它绝对变成了别的东西。当然，它根植于阅读的快乐以及我一直从小说中获得的乐趣。但发生的事情是，我到了一个地步，我真的不在乎它是不是文笔低劣、情节糟糕或者角色毫无吸引力。我只会直接翻到高潮部分（谐音双关）。所以我后来甚至开始阅读非常暴露的色情文学，越暴露越好，性爱场面越多越好。但这全都是为了到达那个时刻并获得某种非常特定、极其美妙的感觉。我掌握了一个秘密：如果你随便拿一本言情小说，把它翻到三分之二或四分之三处，你知道的，你就会直接看到重点，也就是说，这些言情小说是经过精心设计的。它们是按处方编写的。
And then it got where to wear it, like that's all I wanted to do. And I didn't enjoy anything else. I didn't even really want to like be with my kids or my husband, right? I just wanted those times to rush through them so that I could go back to reading romance novels. The other thing that I only realized in retrospect
所以在这一点上，你知道的，你是斯坦福大学备受尊敬的研究员和精神科医生，你有一个美满的家庭。但不再美满了，不久之后就不是了。但这正是我想要问你的，你知道的，你在某些方面所做的事情一定让你觉得与你公开的形象格格不入，你有一种感觉，认为自己是一个母亲，有一个美满的家庭。你是否对你新发现的对香艳文学的热爱感到尴尬？首先，在事情发生的过程中，我并没有真正意识到发生了什么。我偶尔会跟朋友开玩笑说：“哦，我太沉迷于吸血鬼言情小说或一般言情小说了。”但正因为能够拿它开玩笑，我觉得这一定意味着我其实并没有对它上瘾，或者这并不是什么真正的问题。另一件事是，很大程度上由于科技的缘故，我可以秘密进行这种行为。一旦我有了Kindle，你知道的，我就可以在那个Kindle上阅读某些东西，
was that these sort of tamer versions of romance where the sex scenes aren't super graphic, although it stopped working for me. And now I needed ever more graphic types of romance novels in order to get that zing that I was looking for. in order to get that zing that I was looking for. So this was no longer about the pleasure of reading at this point or your love of language, it had become something else. Oh, it had absolutely become something else. And of course, it was rooted in the pleasure of
没有人知道我在读什么。而在以前，我可不想在任何地方被人看到我在读那种书。那会让人觉得非常尴尬。但在Kindle上，这就好比是匿名的。这如何影响你对患者的护理？因为据推测，在这期间你仍在治疗其他患者并帮助人们戒除瘾头。对的。在事情发生的过程中，我并没有真正意识到它的发生，也没有把它与我的患者所经历的事情联系起来。我真的只有在事后才看清这一点。但我开始对我的工作失去兴趣。就像我说的，那些曾经赋予我意义、目标和快乐的工作开始变得暗淡、灰暗和无聊，我发现自己投入度降低了，更多地只是想赶快做完工作，好回家去读言情小说。所以你不在工作时读这些？你把阅读留在了家里。
reading and the pleasure that I've always gotten from fiction. But what happened was I got to a point where I really didn't care if it was badly written or badly plotted or the characters were uninteresting. I would just flip through to the climax pun intended. So then I got to where I was like reading really graphic erotic on the more graphic, the better, the more sex scenes, the better. But it was all about getting to that moment and getting a certain, very specific feeling. And I became the possessor of the knowledge that if you take any romance novel and you open it up to two thirds of three quarters of the way through, you know, you'll get right to the point, which is to say these are these romance novels are engineered. They're written according to a recipe.
嗯，有一天，这大约发生在这一行为的尾声。那时对时间的感知对我来说有点奇怪，但我认为它是在大约一两年内发展起来的。不过我确实把一本言情小说带到了工作单位，在两个患者之间的十分钟空隙里阅读。所以，我不想扮演业余精神科医生，但看起来你确实……没关系。没关系。你知道的，你在这些书里寄托你的情感，
So at this point, you know, you're a respected researcher in psychiatrists at Stanford University, you have a great family. But no longer, soon to be no longer. But that's what I want to ask you about, you know, you have, you know, what you are doing in some ways must have felt at odds with your public persona, the sense that you had, that you were a mom, that you had a great family. Were you embarrassed by your newfound love
将其作为一种逃避。你觉得你在逃避什么？嗯，这正是最迷人的地方。我真的没什么可逃避的。我有一个非常棒的丈夫。我有这些非常棒的孩子。我有一份我深爱的工作。我的患者们都太棒了。没有任何不对劲的地方。我其实只是在逃往别处。而我逃往的地方
of steamy literature? First of all, I didn't really see what was happening as it was happening. I would occasionally joke to friends, oh, I'm so addicted to vampire romance novels or romance novels in general, but just by being able to joke about it, I felt that that must mean I'm really not addicted to it or it's not really a problem. The other thing was that because of the technology in large part, I could do the behavior secretly. Once I got the Kindle, you know, I could be reading something on that Kindle
仅仅是不必存在于我的身体里，不必思考，能够体验到这种强烈的欣快感，你知道的，去往这个对我来说非常非常愉悦的另一个地方，感觉真的很棒。我想在这里强调的另一件事是，我们一次又一次看到的这种模式，即某种东西一开始是令人愉快的。所以你的朋友向你推荐了这本言情小说。你读了《暮光之城》。你觉得很有趣。你觉得很享受。所以你回头寻找更多。但在这个过程的某个地方，平衡发生了转移。现在你其实已经不再因为它们能给你带来快乐而阅读这些东西了。
that nobody else knew what I was reading. Whereas before, I wouldn't want to be seen reading that anywhere. That would just be really embarrassing. But on a Kindle, like it was anonymous. How did this affect your patient care? Because presumably through all of this, you were still treating other patients and helping people with their addictions. Right. As it was happening, I didn't really see it happening and I didn't relate it as being
而是，你知道的，你阅读它们几乎是为了逃避痛苦。因为……不是这样吗？这真的是关键：我们开始从事任何行为都是出于理性的原因，并且它成功实现了我们试图达到的目标，要么给我们带来快乐，要么实现其他一些目标。但如果它随后劫持了我们的大脑或奖赏通路，它就会拥有自己的生命。然后，甚至当它停止做我们想让它做的事情时，我们也无法停下来。这真的是成瘾的标志。稍后回来，我们将探讨日益全球化的怪病背后的脑科学。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。
similar to what my patients were going through. That I really only saw in retrospect. But it started to be less interested in my work. Like again, the work that had given me meaning and purpose and joy started to be dull and gray and boring, and I found myself less engaged and more just wanted to rush through the work so that I could go home and read romance novels. So you weren't reading these at work? You reserved the reading at home.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。安娜·兰姆克是斯坦福大学的精神病学家和行为科学研究员。她是《多巴胺国度：在纵欲时代寻找平衡》一书的作者。安娜，你的许多患者都饱受强迫性过度消费相关问题的困扰，你自己也经历过其中的一部分，但你比你的患者有一个巨大的优势。你是一位研究大脑的研究员和科学家，你了解神经科学中一个非常重要的发现，它与大脑内部痛苦与快乐之间的关系有关。
Well, there was one day, and this was sort of near the sort of combination of this behavior. Time is weird for me then, but I think it developed over the course of about a year or two. But I did bring a Roman Savocha work and was reading in the ten minutes between patients. So, I don't want to play armchair psychiatrist, but it seems that you were. That's okay. That's okay. You know, you were using your emotion in these books
这个发现是什么？这个发现就是痛苦和快乐在大脑中是同域定位的。因此，处理快乐的大脑相同区域也处理痛苦，它们的作用就像天平的两侧。差不多就像一个跷跷板？完全正确。
as a kind of escape. What do you think you were escaping from? Well, that's what's so fascinating. I really didn't have anything to escape from. I have a great husband. I have got these great kids. I have work that I adore. My patients are just so fantastic. There was nothing wrong. I was really just escaping too. And the thing
就像儿童游乐场里的跷跷板或摇摆木板。当那个跷跷板或中心支点上的横梁与地面水平时，它就处于静止状态。这就是神经科学家所说的稳态。当我们体验快乐时，它会向一侧倾斜；当我们体验痛苦时，它会向相反方向倾斜。有些规则支配着这种平衡。第一个也是最重要的规则是，平衡希望保持水平。也就是处于稳态。在我们经历了任何偏离中立状态的事情后，我们的大脑会努力恢复水平
that I was escaping too was just not having to be in my body, not having to think, being able to experience this kind of intense euphoria, you know, this other place, which was very, very pleasant for me, just it just felt good. The other thing I just want to flag here is that the pattern we've seen over and over again, which is that something starts out being pleasurable. So your friend tells you about this romance novel. You read the Twilight saga. You find it fun. You find it enjoyable. And so you go back for more. But somewhere along this process, sort of the balance shifts. And now you're no longer actually reading these things because they're giving you pleasure.
平衡。所以当我们伸手去拿令人愉快的东西时——例如，当我咬下一块美味的甜点时——我是在想象我基本上按下了那个跷跷板的快乐一侧。没错。所以当我们做一些愉快的事情并在奖赏通路中释放多巴胺、使平衡向快乐一侧倾斜时，事情刚一发生，我们的大脑就会非常努力地恢复平衡，它们首先是通过向痛苦一侧倾斜相等且相反的量，然后才回到水平位置。我喜欢把这想象成这些小小的
It's that, you know, you're reading them almost to avoid pain. Because that's not right. That's really the key that we start out doing whatever the behavior is for rational reasons and it succeeds in achieving what we're trying to achieve, either to give us pleasure or to accomplish some other goal. But if it then hijacks our brains or word pathway, it gets a life of its own. And then even when it stops doing what we want it to do, we can't stop. And that's really the hallmark of addiction. When we come back, the brain science behind an increasingly global melody. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam.
神经适应小精灵跳到了平衡的痛苦一侧。这就是情绪低落、宿醉、后效。这种情况经常发生，甚至在我们还在体验多巴胺冲击的时候就已经发生了，而且它通常发生在无意识的情况下。所以如果我有这样一个画面：按下跷跷板的一侧，而这些小精灵跳到了另一侧，为什么它们想要按下痛苦的一侧？为什么不直接尝试达到平衡呢？为什么要按得那么厉害，以至于向另一侧倾斜？这是一个很好的问题，我并不确切知道为什么机制要这样建造，为什么我们为每一份快乐都要付出代价，但我怀疑这与以下事实有关：这种机制使我们成为终极的
This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Analemki is a psychiatrist and researcher in the behavioral sciences at Stanford University. She's the author of Dopamine Nation, Finding Balance in the Age of Indulgence. On a many of your patients suffered from problems related to compulsive overconsumption, and you experienced some of this yourself, but you had a big advantage over your patients. You were a researcher and a scientist who studies the brain, and you knew about a very important discovery in neuroscience that has to do with the relationship between pain and pleasure
寻求者，永远对我们拥有的东西不满足，总是寻找更多。如果你想想看，我们在数百万年的进化中进化出了接近快乐、回避痛苦的本能。除此之外，你还有这种快乐-痛苦平衡，即一旦我们得到了我们正在寻找的任何奖励，我们体验到快乐，我们就会立即记住在哪里以及如何发生这种情况，并希望重现它。而这种重现由于以下事实而加速：一旦我们得到了多巴胺的冲击，
inside the brain. What was this discovery? This discovery was the fact that pain and pleasure are co-located in the brain. So the same parts of the brain, that process, pleasure, also process pain, and they work like opposite sides of a balance. So almost like a seesaw? Exactly.
我们基本上就进入了多巴胺自由落体状态。这就是平衡痛苦一侧的那些小精灵。现在我们处于多巴胺赤字状态，我们感到了采取行动获取下一个奖励的压倒性动力，对于人类的大多数生存历史来说，这意味着每天步行几十公里，涉及大量的劳动，只为了得到一点点奖励。
Like a seesaw or a teeter totter in a kid's playground. And when that teeter totter or that beam on a central fulcrum is level with the ground, it's at rest. Humber what neuroscientists call homeostasis. And when we experience pleasure, it tips one way and when we experience pain, it tips in the opposite direction. And there are certain rules governing this balance. And the first and most important rule is that the balance wants to remain level. That is at homeostasis. And our brains will work very hard to restore a level
所以并不是说多巴胺是好是坏，而是多巴胺对生存至关重要，它让我们保持行动，并总是寻找下一个目标。因此，多巴胺不仅参与体验快乐，也许更重要的是，它还参与动机，当然，这正是你刚才所说的。你能解释一下多巴胺作为快乐信使与多巴胺作为动机建筑师之间的这种联系吗？是的，有一个非常著名的实验，科学家通过生物工程培育出没有大脑奖赏通路多巴胺受体的老鼠。
balance after any deviation from neutrality. So when we reach for things that are pleasurable when I bite into a delicious dessert, for example, I'm imagining that I'm essentially pressing down on the pleasure side of that CISA. That's right. So when we do something that's pleasurable and we release, stoke me in the reward pathway and the balance tilt to the side of pleasure, no sooner has that happened than our brains will work very hard to restore a level balance and they do that first by tilting an equal and opposite amount to the side of pain before going back to the level position. And I like to imagine that is these little
科学家们发现，如果他们把食物放进老鼠嘴里，老鼠会吃食物并似乎从中获得快乐，但如果他们把食物哪怕放在（离老鼠）仅仅一个体长的距离，老鼠就会饿死。换句话说，我们需要多巴胺，不仅是为了体验快乐，也是为了去做工以获得奖励的动力。多巴胺让我们产生动力的可能方式，就是制造这种多巴胺赤字状态，或者说平衡痛苦一侧的那些小精灵。那么，当我们把这个经过数百万年进化的大脑带到现代环境中——在这里，一切
neuro-adaptation gremlins hopping on the pain side of the balance. And that's the come down, the hang over it, the after effect. And it often happens, even while we're still experiencing the dopamine hit, and it often happens outside of conscious awareness. So if I have this image here about pressing down
现在触手可得——会发生什么呢？这种让我们在快乐的直接后果中体验到痛苦的古老神经回路，与我们的现代生态系统严重不匹配。为什么？因为我们被快乐所包围。与人类历史上的任何时期相比，我们有更多机会获得更多具有强化作用的毒品和行为。甚至连以前可以被认为是健康的事情，比如阅读、锻炼或玩游戏，都已经变得毒品化了，在某种程度上变成了毒品，使我们所有人都更容易受到成瘾问题的伤害，也让我们更容易
on one side of the seesaw and these gremlins are jumping on the other side, why is it they want to press down on the side of pain? Why not just try and get to equilibrium? Why press down so much that it tips over in the other direction? That's a great question, and I don't exactly know why the mechanism is built like that, why we pay a price for every pleasure, but I suspect it has to do with the fact that that kind of mechanism makes us the ultimate
在跷跷板的一侧，而这些小精怪跳在另一侧，为什么它们想把痛苦的那一侧往下压呢？为什么不试着达到平衡呢？为什么要压得那么厉害，以至于向相反的方向倾斜？这是个很好的问题，我并不完全清楚为什么机制要这样设计，为什么我们为每一次快乐都要付出代价，但我怀疑这与这种机制使我们成为终极
seekers never satisfied with what we have, always looking for more. And if you think about it, we are evolved over millions of years of evolution to approach, pleasure, and avoid pain. And then on top of that, you have this pleasure pain balance whereby as soon as we get whatever reward we're looking for, we experience pleasure, we immediately remember where and how that happened and we want to recreate it. And that recreation is accelerated by the fact that as soon as we get that hit of dopamine,
追求者有关，对拥有的东西永远不满足，总是在寻找更多。如果你仔细想想，我们在数百万年的进化中，进化出了趋利避害的本能。不仅如此，你们还有这种快乐与痛苦的平衡，一旦我们得到了我们正在寻找的任何奖励，我们就会体验到快乐，我们会立即记住这是在哪里以及如何发生的，并且我们想要重新创造它。而这种重新创造被以下事实加速了：一旦我们得到了多巴胺的刺激，
we essentially go into dopamine free fall. That's those gremlins on the pain side of the balance. And now we're in a dopamine deficit state and we feel this overwhelming motivation to do the work it takes to get the next reward, which for most of human existence has meant walking tens of kilometers every day, has involved doing enormous work in order to get just a little bit of reward.
我们基本上就进入了多巴胺的自由落体状态。这就是平衡痛苦一侧的那些小精怪。现在我们处于多巴胺赤字状态，我们感到了巨大的动力去做那些需要付出努力才能获得下一个奖励的工作，在人类的大部分生存历史中，这意味着每天步行几十公里，需要付出巨大的努力才能获得一点点奖励。
So it's not that dopamine is good or bad, it's that dopamine is essential for survival and it keeps us moving and always looking for the next thing. So dopamine is not involved only in feeling pleasure, perhaps more importantly, it's also involved in motivation, which is of course what you're talking about just now. Can you explain that connection between dopamine as a messenger of pleasure, but also dopamine as the architect for motivation? Yes, so there's a very famous experiment in which rats were bioengineered to not have dopamine receptors in the reward pathway
所以并不是说多巴胺是好是坏，而是多巴胺对生存至关重要，它让我们不断前进，总是寻找下一个目标。因此，多巴胺不仅参与体验快乐，或许更重要的是，它还参与了动力，这当然就是你刚才所说的。你能解释一下多巴胺作为快乐信使的联系，以及多巴胺作为动力建筑师的联系吗？是的，有一个非常著名的实验，其中的老鼠经过生物工程改造，在奖赏通路中没有多巴胺受体
of the brain. And what the scientists discovered was that if they put food into the rat's mouth, the rat would eat the food and seem to get pleasure from the food, but if they put the food even, you know, a single body length away, the rat would starve to death. In other words, we need dopamine, not just for the experience of pleasure, but also for the motivation to do the work to go get the reward. And probably the way that dopamine makes us motivated is to create this dopamine deficit state or those gremlins on the pain side of the balance. So what happens when we transport this brain that evolved over millions of years into the modern environment where everything is
的大脑。科学家们发现，如果他们把食物放进老鼠嘴里，老鼠会吃食物并似乎从食物中获得快乐，但如果他们把食物哪怕放在一个身体长度远的地方，老鼠也会饿死。换句话说，我们需要多巴胺，不仅是为了体验快乐，也是为了获得动力去付出努力去获取奖励。多巴胺促使我们产生动力的原因，可能是创造了这种多巴胺赤字状态，或者是平衡痛苦一侧的那些小精怪。因此，当我们把这个在数百万年中进化的大脑带到现代环境中时，这里的一切
now available at the touch of a button? This ancient wiring that has us experiencing pain in the immediate aftermath of pleasure is woefully mismatched for our modern ecosystem. Why? Because we are surrounded by pleasure. We have more access to more reinforcing drugs and behaviors than at any point in human history. Even things that previously, you could have thought of as healthy, like reading or exercise, or playing games has become a drugified, has been turned into a drug in some way, making us all more vulnerable to the problem of addiction, and also making us more vulnerable to
现在只需按一下按钮就可以得到？这种让我们在快乐的立即余波中体验到痛苦的古老神经连线，与我们的现代生态系统严重不匹配。为什么？因为我们被快乐所包围。我们比人类历史上的任何时候都更能接触到更多强化的药物和行为。甚至以前你可以认为是健康的活动，比如阅读、锻炼或玩游戏，也已经变成了一种药物化，在某种程度上变成了一种药物，使我们所有人都更容易受到成瘾问题的侵害，也使我们更容易受到
the problem of this dopamine deficit state whereby our brains try to compensate for this excess of pleasure by down-regulating our own dopamine production and transmission, not just a baseline, but below baseline, creating this constant physiologic craving for more pleasure, but also the things that go along with craving, which are anxiety, irritability, and depression. So the mechanisms in our brain that compel us to approach pleasure and avoid pain, you say, were evolved over millions of years for a world of scarcity, whereas today, because we're surrounded by so much stuff, we're sort of drinking from a fire hose of dopamine as you put it. Yeah, this is the plenty paradox, right?
多巴胺赤字状态的问题在于，我们的大脑试图通过下调自身的产生和传输来补偿过量的快乐，不仅降到基线水平以下，而且创造了一种对更多快乐的生理渴望，同时也伴随着焦虑、易怒和抑郁等渴望带来的负面影响。因此，你提到过，我们大脑中促使我们追求快乐、避开痛苦的机制是在数百万年的资源匮乏世界中进化而来的，而今天，由于我们被太多的东西包围，我们就像你所说的那样，在用消防栓喝多巴胺。是的，这就是丰裕悖论，对吧？
It's the literal physiologic stress of overabundance. So walk me through the same CSA analogy that we talked about earlier. You know, again, a hundred thousand years ago, you know, I found a date tree and the date tree had delicious dates, and it made my brain very happy to eat some of those dates but they were not very many dates on that one tree I had to find the next tree and the next tree might have been as you say three miles away and so it required a huge amount of effort to get to that next date tree. What's happening with that seesaw now in the world in which we live where things are in fact available at the touch of a button? Yeah, well let's go back for a second and talk about what's happening with the seesaw
这就是过度丰裕带来的字面意义上的生理压力。那么，请带我重新审视我们之前讨论过的关于脑筋急转弯的比喻。你知道，同样在十万年前，我发现了一棵枣树，枣树上有美味的枣子，吃一些枣子让我的大脑非常快乐，但那棵树上并没有多少枣子，我必须找到下一棵树，而下一棵树可能正如你所说，在三英里之外，因此需要付出巨大的努力才能到达下一棵枣子树。在我们今天生活的这个只需按一下按钮就能买到东西的世界里，那个跷跷板现在发生了什么？是的，那么我们先退回一步，谈谈跷跷板发生了什么
when you're looking for the date tree. Because what happens as you're scouring your environment to try to find, you know, one date tree with a couple of dates on it is that your pleasure pain balance goes onto the pain side, right? Because you're hungry and you're walking and you're tired. And then finally, you find this date tree and you, you know, you're ecstatic and you eat this date and your balance, your pleasure pain balance, goes back to the level position, which feels like euphoria because part of the key here
当你寻找枣树的时候。因为当你四处搜寻环境，试图找到一棵长着几个枣子的枣树时，你的快乐与痛苦平衡就会倾向于痛苦的一侧，对吧？因为你饿了，你在走路，你很累。然后终于，你找到了这棵枣树，你欣喜若狂，你吃下这个枣子，你的平衡，你的快乐痛苦平衡，回到了水平位置，这感觉就像是欣快感，因为这里的关键部分之一
is the directionality of the pleasure pain balance. So if I'm in pain because I'm hungry, and then I find something to eat and it moves me in the direction of pleasure That's as pleasurable as if I start out with a level balance and I use an intoxicant and I get high Interesting and so now the same pain pleasure or balance now what happens now? Yeah, so now in the modern world Let's say yet take Silicon Valley because it's a prime example, but it's also true all over the world now. You go and you're hungry, right? And you're looking for a date tree and all of a sudden, you know, you've got like a whole crate of dates shipped to you from Amazon right on your kitchen table.
是快乐与痛苦平衡的方向性。所以，如果我因为饥饿而痛苦，然后我找到了吃的东西，它推动我朝着快乐的方向发展，这就像我从一个平衡的状态开始，然后使用兴奋剂并感到兴奋一样快乐，很有趣。那么现在同样的痛苦与快乐平衡，现在会发生什么？是的，所以在现代世界里，让我们以硅谷为例，因为它是一个典型的例子，但现在世界各地也是如此。你去的时候饿了，对吧？你在找一棵枣树，突然之间，你知道，亚马逊直接在你的餐桌上给你运来了一整箱枣子。
And by the way, they're giant. Like they're like abnormally giant dates, right? So you eat a giant date from Amazon, and it releases dopamine in your reward path, because they've also added sugar and salt and fat and flavorings. It's like coffee dates or something who knows. And you get the release of dopamine. And wow, that feels great, because like, wow,
顺便说一句，它们很大。就像它们是异常巨大的枣子一样，对吧？所以你吃了亚马逊寄来的一个巨大的巨型枣子，它会在你的奖赏通路中释放多巴胺，因为他们还添加了糖、盐、脂肪和调味品。这有点像咖啡枣或类似的东西，谁知道呢。你得到了多巴胺的释放。哇，感觉太棒了，因为，哇，
who's ever had a date like that in the history of humans. And then, you know, as soon as it's over, your pleasure pain balanced, tips to the side of pain, because those gremlins are trying to compensate for all that dopamine. And as soon as you're in that dopamine deficit state with the gremlins on the pain side of the balance, you want to restore a level balance. And what is the easiest way to do that? Well, you could wait till the gremlins hop off, because if you wait long enough, they will hop off and homeostasis will be restored or you could eat another date. And if you eat another date, because there's a whole crate of dates right in front of you, that would work faster, right? And maybe you'll eat to this time because then that'll level your balance, but also get you over
在人类历史上，谁曾吃过这样的枣子。然后，你知道，一旦结束，你的快乐与痛苦平衡就会向痛苦的一侧倾斜，因为那些小精灵正试图补偿所有的多巴胺。一旦你处于这种带有小精灵的多巴胺赤字状态，处于平衡的痛苦一侧，你就会想要恢复平衡。最简单的方法是什么？嗯，你可以等到小精灵跳下来，因为如果你等得够久，他们会跳下来的，体内平衡就会恢复；或者你可以再吃一颗枣子。如果你再吃一颗枣子，因为你面前整整有一箱枣子，那会更快见效，对吧？也许这次你会吃到饱，因为那样不仅能平衡你的平衡，还能让你超越
to the pleasure side. And pretty soon you've eaten the whole crate of dates. And now you're essentially at war with those neuro-adaptation gremlins. And the more we then try and press down on the pleasure side of the seesaw, and the more the gremlins try and press down on the other side to achieve homeostasis, you make the case that over time the gremlins start to push down on the opposite side of achieve homeostasis, you make the case that over time, the gremlins start to push down on the opposite side of the seesaw and then we end up depressed and anxious. Explain how this happens on it.
到快乐的一侧。很快你就会吃掉整箱枣子。现在你基本上是在与那些神经适应小精灵交战。我们越是试图压低跷跷板快乐的一侧，小精灵越是试图压低另一侧以达到体内平衡，你就会发现，随着时间的推移，小精灵开始向下推跷跷板的另一侧，最终我们会陷入抑郁和焦虑。解释一下这是如何发生的。
Well, what happens as we continually bombard our reward pathway with highly reinforcing substances and behaviors is that we accumulate more and more gremlins on the pain side of the balance. They're just doing their job, you know, trying to restore homeostasis. And over time, you know, those gremlins essentially are camped out on the pain side of the balance, tense and barbecues in tow. And now we're in addicted brain. We've changed our hedonic or joy set point, such that now we need more of our drug, quantity-wise, and more potent forms of our drug, not to get high, but just to level the balance and feel normal. And most importantly, when we're not using, we're walking around with a pleasure-paying
嗯，当我们不断用高度强化的物质和行为轰炸我们的奖赏通路时，会在平衡的痛苦一侧积聚越来越多的小精灵。他们只是在做他们的工作，试图恢复体内平衡。随着时间的推移，你知道，这些小精灵基本上是在平衡的痛苦一侧安营扎寨，带着帐篷和烧烤炉。现在我们成了上瘾的大脑。我们改变了我们的快乐设定点，以至于现在我们需要更多的药物（就数量而言），以及更强效的药物形式，不是为了嗨，而只是为了平衡并感觉正常。最重要的是，当我们不使用时，我们走来走去，带着快乐与痛苦的
balance tilted to the side of pain, which means we are experiencing the universal symptoms of withdrawal from any addictive substance, which are anxiety, irritability, insomnia, depression, and craving. I mean, you're an addiction psychiatrist and you treat many patients who are dependent on drugs. So drugs in the conventional sense of a chemical that is swallowed or smoked or snorted or ingested. And obviously, that is a very big problem. But, you know, you're making a much more radical claim here. You're saying that a problem with addiction is not just limited to nicotine and cocaine and heroin.
平衡向痛苦的一侧倾斜，这意味着我们正在经历对任何成瘾物质的戒断的普遍症状，即焦虑、易怒、失眠、抑郁和渴望。我的意思是，你是一位成瘾精神病学家，你治疗了许多对药物成瘾的患者。所以，这里的药物是指传统意义上被吞咽、吸烟、鼻吸或摄入的化学物质。显然，这是一个非常大的问题。但是，你知道，你在这里提出了一个更激进的观点。你说成瘾问题不仅限于尼古丁、可卡因和海洛因。
You're absolutely right. What I'm saying is that science, technology and innovation has allowed us to drugify almost every human behavior. If you're not addicted yet, it's coming soon to a website near you. And my bigger claim is that the rising rates of depression, anxiety, and suicide, which by the way are rising fastest in the richest nations in the world, are due in part to the fact that we are overloading our brains reward pathway with too much dopamine. And that in our brains effort to compensate for too much pleasure, we are essentially individually and collectively down-regulating our own dopamine production and transmission,
你说得对。我的意思是科学、技术和创新使我们能够将几乎所有的现代人类行为都药物化。如果你还没有上瘾，它很快就会在附近的某个网站上出现。我更大的主张是，抑郁、焦虑和自杀率的上升（顺便说一句，在世界上最富裕的国家上升最快）部分归因于我们用太多的多巴胺超载了我们大脑的奖赏通路。在我们大脑努力补偿过多快乐的过程中，我们在个体和集体层面上实质性地下调了我们自己的多巴胺产生和传输，
not just to baseline levels, but actually below baseline levels. So we are in a dopamine deficit state, which means that we're all unhappier, more anxious, more depressed, more irritable, less able to take joy in the things that used to give us joy or that have given people joy for generations, and also more susceptible to paint, right? Even the mirror's slight now can make us paint and that we're not, this isn't happening because somehow we're spoiled or our values have changed, it's because we've literally physiologically changed our brains as a result of constantly
不仅降到基线水平，实际上降到了基线水平以下。所以我们处于多巴胺赤字状态，这意味着我们所有人都更加不快乐、更焦虑、更抑郁、更易怒，从那些过去给我们带来快乐或几代人带来快乐的事物中获得快乐的能力下降了，而且更容易感到痛苦，对吧？甚至微小的挫折现在也能让我们痛苦，这不是因为我们被宠坏了或者我们的价值观改变了，而是因为我们通过不断地轰炸大脑，字面意义上在生理上改变了我们的大脑
bombarding them with these high reward substances and behaviors. So in some ways this feels really mind-bending to meana because you know I can see how nicotine and alcohol and marijuana or heroin or cocaine. I can see how these could be addictive but many of the things you're talking about, you know, food or social connection or sexual intimacy, these are not things that are inherently problems. In fact, many of them are part of what it means to be human. Talk about how our modern societies have taken these normal healthy things, and in effect, as you would put it, drugify them. So the way that our modern society has drugified these things that used to be normal and healthy like having sex or eating food or playing games is essentially by increasing four factors, quantity, access, potency and novelty. novelty because our incredible manufacturing system has allowed us to make
用这些高回报的物质和行为。所以在某些方面，这对我来说真的很震撼，安娜，因为我知道我看清了尼古丁、酒精、大麻、海洛因或可卡因是如何让人上瘾的，但我能看出这些东西是如何让人上瘾的，但你谈到的许多事情，你知道，食物、社交联系或性亲密，这些都不是本身就有问题的事情。事实上，其中许多是作为人类的意义的一部分。谈谈我们的现代社会如何将这些正常健康的事物进行药物化，正如你所说的那样。所以我们的现代社会将这些曾经正常和健康的事情（如做爱、吃食物或玩游戏）进行药物化的方式，本质上是通过增加四个因素：数量、获取途径、效力和新鲜感。新鲜感是因为我们令人难以置信的制造系统允许我们制造
these reinforcing substances in enormous quantities and our amazing supply chain allows us to ship them all over the world. You know one of my favorite sort of anecdotes is that in the 1880s the cigarette rolling machine was invented allowing manufacturers of cigarettes to go from manufacturing for cigarettes, a minute to 20,000 cigarettes a minute. That's just one example of what we've done all around. My own romance novel reading addiction that developed. One of the things that I discovered when I went looking for other romance novels is that there's a whole universe of romance
这些具有强化作用的物质数量巨大，我们惊人的供应链使我们能够将它们运往世界各地。你知道，我最喜欢的趣闻之一是，在1880年代，卷烟机的发明使卷烟制造商能够将每分钟制造4支香烟提高到每分钟制造20,000支香烟。这只是我们在各地所做事情的一个例子。我自己的言情小说阅读成瘾就是这样发展的。当我寻找其他言情小说时，我发现的事情之一是存在着整个言情小说宇宙
novels out there. There was no, it was really a never-ending quantity. And quantity really matters because the more we use our drug of choice, our substance or behavior that's reinforcing, the more that we expose our brains to and the more often, the more likely we are to change our brains to this addicted kind of circuitry. So quantity is the first driver. What are the others? Yeah, so quantity is the first one.
那里的小说。没有限制，真的是一个永无止境的数量。数量真的很重要，因为我们使用我们选择的药物、物质或具有强化作用的行为越多，我们暴露给大脑的次数就越多、频率就越高，我们越有可能将大脑改变成这种成瘾的回路。所以数量是第一个驱动力。其他的是什么？是的，所以数量是第一个驱动力。
Availability or access is huge. So if you grow up in a neighborhood where drugs are sold in the street corner, we have lots of epidemiologic data showing that you're more likely to try drugs and more likely to get addicted to them. And now we live in a world where we all have more access to our substance or behavior of choice, whether it's vampire romance novels or potato chips or games or pornography or you know old-fashioned drugs like alcohol, cannabis and
可用性或获取途径是巨大的。如果你在一个毒品在街角出售的社区长大，我们有大量的流行病学数据表明你更有可能尝试毒品并且更有可能对它们上瘾。现在我们生活在一个对我们选择的物质或行为有更多获取途径的世界里，无论是吸血鬼言情小说、薯片、游戏、色情制品，还是老式的毒品，如酒精、大麻和
nicotine. And of course the smartphone is essentially the equivalent of the hypodermic syringe delivering digital dopamine 24-7 for our wired generation and that's really what it is. The smartphone totally changed things. When people could carry in their pocket this device that gave them the access to digital media and digital content 24-7, we all essentially became more addicted to these kinds of digital drugs. All right, so we've talked about quantity and we've talked about accessibility. What's next?
尼古丁。当然，智能手机本质上相当于皮下注射针筒，为我们这个网瘾一代24-7小时提供数字多巴胺，这确实就是它所扮演的角色。智能手机彻底改变了事情。当人们可以把这个能够让他们24-7小时访问数字媒体和数字内容的设备放进口袋时，我们本质上都对这些数字药物更加上瘾了。好了，我们讨论了数量，也讨论了获取途径。接下来是什么？
Yeah, availability accessibility. And the other one is potency. So one of the ways to overcome these gremlins on the pain side of the balance, or what's often referred to as tolerance, is to either use more of the drug or use more potent forms or have a more potent drug delivery mechanism. So for example, with opioids, someone might start out using opium, but eventually go to heroin, which is about 10 times more potent, and then eventually progress to fentanyl, which is 5200 times more potent. And this would allow them to at least temporarily win that battle with their gremlins and get the feeling that they're looking for. But another way to
是的，可用性和获取途径。另一个是效力。因此，克服平衡痛苦一侧的这些小精灵（通常被称为耐受性）的方法之一，要么是使用更多的药物，要么是使用更强效的形式，或者拥有更强效的药物输送机制。例如，对于阿片类药物，某人可能从使用鸦片开始，但最终会转向海洛因（效力约为其10倍），然后最终发展为芬太尼（效力为5200倍）。这将使他们至少暂时赢得与小精灵的战斗，并获得他们正在寻找的感觉。但另一种方法
achieve potency is to combine two drugs to make yet a third more novel drug. And this is done all the time. For example, people combining opioids with things like benzodiazepines or now this new veterinary sedative trink, which people are sadly using. By combining two distinct drugs together, we get a new novel drug, which then changes it up for our brain receptors and allows us to overcome tolerance. And in the realm of non-illegal substances,
实现效力的方法是将两种药物结合起来制造出第三种更新颖的药物。这种做法一直在发生。例如，人们将阿片类药物与苯二氮卓类药物结合使用，或者现在这种人们不幸在使用的新的兽用镇静剂曲拉太尼。通过将两种截然不同的药物结合在一起，我们得到了一种新的新颖药物，这随后改变了我们大脑受体的情况，并使我们能够克服耐受性。而在非违禁物质的领域，
you can also have combinations like French toast ice cream. Exactly. Or, you know, I very easily get hooked on YouTube videos, especially outtakes of American Idol. When I think about why on earth is American Idol so entrancing for me, well, they've figured it out. They've taken music, which is already reinforcing for most people's brains, releases dopamine, feels good. And then they've combined that with gaming and they've turned it into a competition and thereby really made a very potent drug.
你也可以有法式吐司冰淇淋这样的组合。没错。或者，你知道，我很容易沉迷于YouTube视频，尤其是美国偶像的幕后花絮。当我想到为什么美国偶像对我如此着迷时，嗯，他们找到了诀窍。他们采用了对大多数人的大脑已经具有强化作用、释放多巴胺、感觉良好的音乐。然后他们将其与游戏结合起来，将其变成了一场比赛，从而真正制造了一种非常强效的药物。
Can you talk a moment about the factor that's known as novelty? This is true in drugs of abuse, but it's also true for many of the other things that previously we might not have thought as being problematic. Yeah, so dopamine is extremely sensitive to novelty, which is why for example people can get addicted to things like the news. That's the definition of news. It's new stuff coming your way. But what's become so toxic about the modern world is that in order to maintain customers and
你能谈谈被称为新鲜感的那个因素吗？这在滥用药物中是真实的，但对于我们以前可能没有认为是有问题的许多其他事情来说也是真实的。是的，多巴胺对新鲜感极其敏感，这就是为什么例如人们会对诸如新闻之类的事情上瘾的原因。这就是新闻的定义。这是流向你的新鲜事物。但现代社会变得如此具有毒性的原因是，为了留住客户并
keep them coming back, you've got to take the thing that they like before and then package it as slightly new or different or better. The internet has absolutely mastered that, right? These AI algorithms learn us, figure out where we've spent time before, what we've liked before, and then profit or suggest to us things that are similar, but a little bit different. That absolutely engages this treasure-seeking function where we keep going because we're hoping that the next hit will be something that's just a little bit better, but similar to what we had before.
让他们再次光顾，你必须把他们以前喜欢的东西拿来，然后把它包装成略有新意、不同或更好的东西。互联网绝对掌握了这一点，对吧？这些人工智能算法了解我们，弄清楚我们以前在哪里花费了时间，我们以前喜欢什么，然后向我们推荐或提供类似但略有不同的东西。这绝对吸引了这种寻宝功能，我们不断前行，因为我们希望下一次的冲击会更好一点，但类似于我们以前拥有的东西。
You know, I remember when I was in 8th grade, or maybe 7th grade, on teachers would tell me to avoid a local park, me and all of my classmates, because the rumor was that drugs were being bought and sold and used at this park. But if everything can be drugified, if addictions can be beamed and streamed and wified into our living rooms and bedrooms, it becomes really now very hard to put a fence around it and say avoid going to this park, because the problem is no longer just with one park. That's the problem we're all facing as individuals, as parents, as schools. I mean, I don't know about you, but when I walk around and see the way that people are
你知道，我记得我在8年级或7年级时，老师告诉我以及我所有的同班同学避开当地的一个公园，因为有传言说这个公园里正在买卖和使用毒品。但如果一切都可以被药物化，如果成瘾可以被发射、流媒体传输和无线传输到我们的客厅和卧室里，现在要在这个公园周围筑起篱笆说避免去这个公园变得非常困难，因为问题不再仅仅局限于一个公园。这就是我们作为个人、父母、学校所有人都在面临的问题。我的意思是，我不知道你怎么样，但当我四处走动看到人们
just glued to their phones, it just makes me really sad. And yet I totally get it. I mean, these things are, they're literally mesmerizing. We are put in a trance by these devices. They're highly reinforcing for our very fragile little human brains. When we combine the ancient pleasure pain CISO in the brain, with a modern world that is ready to push hard and often on the pleasure side of the balance. We get trouble. We end up with compulsive overconsumption and all the associated problems it causes for people's health, well-being and relationships.
只是粘在手机上，这真的让我很难过。然而我完全理解。我的意思是，这些东西，它们简直令人着迷。我们被这些设备催眠了。它们对我们非常脆弱的小人类大脑具有高度的强化作用。当我们结合大脑中古老的快乐与痛苦跷跷板时，伴随着一个准备在平衡快乐一侧猛烈且频繁推动的现代世界。我们就遇到了麻烦。我们最终陷入了强迫性过度消费以及它给人们的健康、福祉和关系带来的所有相关问题。
We also end up with a plague of depression and anxiety. In the second part of our story, coming up in the next episode, how to reset our relationship with a world of plenty and turn unhappiness into thriving? Anna Lemke, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Oh, you're very welcome. If you have follow-up questions that you'd like to ask Anna and that you'd be comfortable sharing with a larger hidden brain audience, please send a voice memo to ideas at hiddenbrain.org. Use the subject line, Addiction. That email address again is ideas at hiddenbrain.org. 60 seconds is plenty, and please be sure to include your name and phone number.
我们也最终陷入了抑郁和焦虑的瘟疫中。在我们的故事的第二部分，将在下一集中播出，如何重置我们与丰裕世界的关系并将不快乐转化为繁荣？安娜·兰姆克，谢谢你今天来到Hidden Brain。哦，不客气。如果你有后续问题想问安娜，并且愿意与更广泛的Hidden Brain听众分享，请发送语音备忘录至ideas at hiddenbrain.org。使用主题行：成瘾。再次重复该电子邮件地址是ideas at hiddenbrain.org。60秒就足够了，请务必附上你的姓名和电话号码。
Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarelle, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Our unsung hero this week is Angelica or Jelly Monteros. Jelly works on the podcast operations team at Apple and she played an essential role in the launch of our new podcast subscription Hidden Brain
Hidden Brain由Hidden Brain Media制作。我们的音频制作团队包括Bridget McCarthy、Annie Murphy Paul、Kristen Wong、Laura Quarelle、Ryan Katz、Autumn Barnes和Andrew Chadwick。Tara Boyle是我们的执行制片人。我是Hidden Brain的执行编辑。我们本周的无名英雄是Angelica或Jelly Monteros。Jelly在Apple的播客运营团队工作，她在我们新播客订阅Hidden Brain
Plus. Jelly is the type of person who seems to know everything, the person that others turn to for help when there's a question or issue to troubleshoot. She knows how to get things done and we're so grateful for all her help. If you would like to help us build more stories like this, please consider joining Hidden Brain Plus. It's where you'll find even more of the ideas and insights that you'll love from the show. Plus you'll have the chance to have your questions answered by researchers we feature on the show. You can find Hidden Brain Plus in the Apple Podcasts app or at apple.co slash Hidden Brain.
Plus的推出中发挥了至关重要的作用。Jelly是一个似乎无所不知的人，当遇到问题或需要解决故障时，其他人都会向她求助。她知道如何把事情办妥，我们非常感谢她提供的所有帮助。如果你想帮助我们创作更多这样的故事，请考虑加入Hidden Brain Plus。在那里你会找到更多你喜爱的节目中的观点和见解。此外，你还有机会让我们在节目中采访的研究人员回答你的问题。你可以在Apple Podcasts应用中或访问apple.co斜杠Hidden Brain找到Hidden Brain Plus。
I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. I'm Shankar Vedantim. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是香卡·维丹坦。再见。我是香卡·维丹坦。再见。本集暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可留下评论。